- Vítej zpět u kurzu Porozumění
kvantovým informacím a výpočtům.
Jmenuji se John Watrous a jsem
technickým ředitelem IBM Quantum Education.
Toto je čtvrtá lekce série a zároveň poslední
lekce první části série věnované základům
kvantových informací.
Dosud jsme si povídali o tom,
jak kvantové informace fungují pro jednotlivé i vícečetné systémy, a podívali jsme se na
model quantum circuit,
a pozorovali jsme některá
zásadní omezení kvantových informací.
Cestou jsme narazili na některé důležité matematické pojmy
včetně tenzorových součinů a skalárních součinů, a budeme
tyto pojmy dále využívat a podle potřeby
budeme zavádět i nové.
V této lekci se zaměříme
na tři zásadní důležité příklady: kvantovou teleportaci, superdense coding a hru CHSH,
která se také nazývá CHSH nerovností a ne vždy bývá popisována jako hra.
Nejde jen o náhodné
příklady, které mají ilustrovat, jak kvantové informace fungují – jsou to skutečně klíčové
části základů
kvantových informací a
objevují se v různých, někdy nečekaných kontextech v oblasti kvantových informací
a výpočtů.
Provázanost hraje klíčovou roli ve všech třech těchto
příkladech, a právě provázanost je to, co je umožňuje
a dělá je zajímavými. Tato lekce bude tedy v jistém smyslu naší první příležitostí
vidět provázanost v akci
a začít zkoumat, co dělá provázanost tak zajímavou.
Přehled lekce je velmi jednoduchý: postupně projdeme
tři příklady, které jsem právě zmínil –
kvantovou teleportaci,
superdense coding a hru CHSH.
Probereme, co to jsou zač a co je dělá zajímavými, a projdeme analýzy, které přesně vysvětlují, jak fungují
na matematické úrovni.
Než se dostaneme k prvnímu
ze tří příkladů – kvantové teleportaci – je vhodné nejprve
představit postavy:
Alici a Boba, v případě, že je
ještě neznáš.
Alice a Bob jsou jména
přidělovaná hypotetickým entitám nebo aktérům v systémech, protokolech, hrách,
a vlastně v jakémkoli jiném typu interakce, při níž dochází k výměně informací.
Poprvé se objevily
v kontextu kryptografie v 70. letech, ale
konvence používat tato jména tímto způsobem se velmi rozšířila
v mnohem širším kontextu od té doby. Myšlenka je taková, že jde o velmi běžná jména, alespoň v některých částech světa, a začínají písmeny A a B,
přičemž je také praktické
odkazovat na Alici a Boba pomocí zájmen ona a on, jen pro stručnost.
Typicky si představujeme, že Alice a Bob jsou na různých místech a mají různé
cíle a různé chování
v závislosti na tom, o čem zrovna mluvíme.
Například pokud hovoříme
o komunikaci, tedy o přenosu informací, můžeme se rozhodnout,
že Alice je odesílatel
a Bob je příjemce
jakýchkoli přenášených informací.
Alice a Bob někdy
spolupracují – to je velmi typické – ale někdy
soupeří nebo mohou mít různé cíle, které mohou nebo nemusí být vzájemně slučitelné,
ale to vše musí být jasně
definováno v dané situaci.
Samozřejmě představují abstrakce a nemusí jít nutně o skutečné lidské bytosti.
Můžeme také zavést
další postavy, například Charlieho a
Diane nebo různá jména představující různé
osoby, například Eve
jako odposlouchávač nebo Mallory pro někoho, kdo se chová zákeřně,
v závislosti na kontextu.
V každém případě se s Alicí a Bobem setkáme ve všech třech
příkladech, které probereme v této lekci, a čas od času
v průběhu zbytku série. Než přejdeme ke třem příkladům, zmíním ještě několik
poznámek o provázanosti.
Ve druhé lekci jsme narazili na tento příklad provázaného stavu dvou qubitů.
Je to jeden ze čtyř Bellových stavů a dalo by se říct, že
tento konkrétní stav představuje archetypální příklad
provázaného kvantového stavu.
Setkali jsme se také s tímto
příkladem pravděpodobnostního stavu dvou bitů.
Je do jisté míry analogický
provázanému stavu, ale není provázaný –
provázanost je výhradně
kvantový jev,
v podstatě z definice.
Existuje přesná matematická definice toho, co je provázanost, a v zásadě tato definice
říká, že provázanost
je neklasická kvantová korelace.
To ale není
příliš nápomocné na intuitivní úrovni – je to definice provázanosti skrze to, čím provázanost není,
a pravděpodobně proto
je opravdu dost obtížné vysvětlit, co provázanost je a co ji dělá zvláštní
intuitivními pojmy.
Když se lidé snaží
vysvětlit provázanost intuitivně, často slyšíš vysvětlení, která ve skutečnosti nerozlišují tyto dva stavy
smysluplným způsobem. Může se říkat, že pokud změříš jeden ze dvou provázaných qubitů,
stav toho druhého
WEBVTT
je nějak okamžitě ovlivněn, nebo že stav dvou provázaných qubitů nelze popisovat odděleně,
nebo že si dva qubity
nějak uchovávají vzájemnou paměť, nebo dokonce
že jsou k sobě emocionálně připoutány.
Ale proč tato vlastnosti
neplatí pro tento stav?
Tyto dva bity jsou těsně propojeny, každý z nich si v doslovném smyslu uchovává dokonalou
paměť toho druhého, ale
přesto nejde o provázaný stav.
Jedním ze způsobů, jak vysvětlit, co dělá provázanost zvláštní a proč je tento stav
velmi odlišný od tohoto stavu, je vysvětlit, co s provázaností
dokážeme
nebo co díky provázanosti
pozorujeme a co přesahuje rozhodnutí, která děláme o tom, jak reprezentovat naše
znalosti pomocí vektorů.
Všechny tři příklady,
které probereme v této lekci, mají tuto povahu v tom, že ilustrují
věci, které dokážeme dělat s provázaností, ale které s tímto stavem
nebo s jakýmkoli klasicky korelovaným stavem nedokážeme.
Ve studiu kvantových informací a výpočtů je velmi typické, že na provázanost pohlížíme jako na zdroj,
prostřednictvím něhož lze splnit různé
úkoly.
A když to děláme, pohlížíme na tento stav jako na
jednu jednotku provázanosti.
Tuto jednotku
provázanosti označujeme jako e-bit, kde e znamená
entangled (provázaný) nebo entanglement (provázanost).
Je pravda, že jde o dva qubity, ale jako množství
provázanosti je to jeden e-bit.
Dvojici obyčejných klasických bitů v korelovaném
pravděpodobnostním stavu, o němž jsme mluvili dříve, můžeš také chápat jako zdroj –
jeden bit sdílené náhodnosti.
Sdílet náhodný bit s někým může být v
kryptografii velmi užitečné za předpokladu,
že nikdo jiný neví, jaký ten bit je, aby
mohl sloužit jako soukromý klíč
nebo jako součást soukromého klíče, například pro šifrování.
V této lekci se ale zaměříme na tento provázaný stav a
věci, které s ním dokážeme dělat.
A jen pro upřesnění terminologie – když říkáme, že Alice
a Bob sdílejí e-bit, máme tím na mysli, že
Alice má qubit jménem A,
Bob má qubit jménem B, a společně je pár A, B
ve stavu Phi plus.
Na názvech dvou qubitů
samozřejmě nezáleží – mohli bychom
zvolit jiná jména, ale v průběhu této lekce
se budeme držet těchto názvů
pro přehlednost. Prvním příkladem lekce
je kvantová teleportace,
kterou budeme od teď pro stručnost
označovat jen jako teleportaci.
Teleportace je protokol, který umožňuje odesílateli
přenést kvantové informace příjemci pouze pomocí provázanosti
a klasické komunikace k
uskutečnění tohoto přenosu.
Nemá to absolutně nic společného s typickým chápáním
slova teleportace ve sci-fi, kde
hmota mizí
na jednom místě a objevuje se na jiném.
Kvantová teleportace je jen název, který má evokovat tuto představu nebo metaforu, takříkajíc.
Co se teleportuje, jsou
kvantové informace, nikoli hmota, a děje se to
prostřednictvím přenosu klasických informací
společně s provázaností.
Abychom přesně pochopili,
jak teleportace funguje, je užitečné nejprve
připravit půdu, takříkajíc.
Představíme si scénář zahrnující Alici a Boba,
a tento scénář je následující:
Alice má qubit jménem Q, který
by chtěla přenést Bobovi – jinými slovy chce, aby Bob měl v rukou
qubit, který je přesně
ve stejném stavu, v jakém je Q na začátku protokolu.
Jinými slovy, hovoříme o základním problému
přenosu informací neboli komunikace.
Máme odesílatele jménem Alice
a příjemce jménem Bob, přičemž Alice chce poslat
kvantové informace ve formě qubitu Bobovi.
Existuje ovšem omezení: Alice
nemůže fyzicky poslat Q Bobovi, vše, co může udělat, je poslat Bobovi klasické informace.
Alice a Bob mají také
dodatečný zdroj – sdílejí e-bit.
Takový je tedy scénář – je snadné si představit situace, kdy omezení, že
Alice nemůže fyzicky poslat Q
Bobovi, je rozumnou abstrakcí.
Pokud by Alice a Bob byli
na různých kontinentech, nebo pokud by Alice neznala
přesnou polohu Boba, fyzické zaslání qubitu
by bylo pravděpodobně poměrně náročné.
Ale klasická komunikace
je za těchto okolností samozřejmě nejen možná, ale také docela levná.
Člověk by se mohl ptát, zda je možné, aby Alice a Bob splnili tento úkol, aniž by vůbec potřebovali sdílený e-bit.
Jinými slovy, existuje
nějaký způsob, jak přenést qubit pouze pomocí klasické
komunikace?
Odpověď je ne – není možné přenášet kvantové informace pouze pomocí klasické komunikace, a to není příliš těžké dokázat
pomocí základní teorie kvantových
informací, kterou uvidíme
ve třetí části série.
Intuitivní způsob, jak
o tom přemýšlet, je uvažovat o teorému o neklonování.
WEBVTT
Představ si, že by existoval způsob,
jak poslat kvantové informace pouze pomocí klasické komunikace.
Klasická komunikace
však lze snadno kopírovat a vysílat, což by znamenalo,
že klasická komunikace
by mohla být vysílána dvěma
příjemcům – Bobovi a Charliemu, řekněme.
Pokud by oba dostali
stejné klasické informace od Alice, skončili by oba s Q?
To by naznačovalo, že jsme Q naklonovali, ale víme, že to je nemožné.
Jen jako vsuvka – konstatujme,
že je samozřejmě možné popsat
vektory kvantových stavů pomocí klasických informací.
Každý vektor kvantového stavu,
který v sérii uvidíš, ti je popisován
pomocí klasických informací přenesených na zařízení,
na němž se díváš.
Obecně bychom si mohli představit,
že popisujeme, ve kterém stavu je Q, pomocí klasických bitů,
třeba s určitou přesností,
ale to není kvantová komunikace – to je jen popisování
kvantových stavů jako vektorů, a k
rozdílu mezi nimi se
vrátíme za chvíli.
Vraťme se ale ke scénáři a pracujme za předpokladu, že Alice a Bob sdílejí e-bit – uvidíme, že Alice a Bob
mají vše potřebné
k splnění úkolu, a to je přesně to, co protokol kvantové teleportace dělá, konkrétně pomocí dvou bitů
klasické komunikace.
Než se ponoříme do
těchto detailů, dovolte mi udělat několik rychlých
poznámek, jen abychom si ujasnili předpoklady.
Zaprvé předpokládáme,
že stav Q je Alici a
Bobovi neznámý, takže zejména
Alice nemůže Bobovi poslat
popis stavu Q, protože ho obecně nezná.
Musíme také zvážit možnost, že Q je korelován s jinými systémy, včetně možnosti,
že je provázán
s jinými systémy, a
přenos tohoto qubitu Bobovi musí tyto korelace zachovat.
Nakonec jsem zmínil
teorém o neklonování, když jsem mluvil o
pokusu komunikovat qubity klasicky, ale
je tu ještě jedno spojení
s teorémem o neklonování, a sice to, že pokud
Bob obdrží přenos tohoto qubitu Q od Alice,
pak ho Alice mít nesmí,
protože Q nelze naklonovat, a na to je třeba pamatovat
při uvažování o protokolu teleportace.
Protokol teleportace
lze popsat poměrně jednoduše a přímo pomocí diagramu quantum circuit, jak vidíš zde.
Je mírně stylizovaný v tom, že znázorňuje oddělení mezi Alicinou částí a Bobovou částí, ale jinak je to jen
diagram quantum circuit,
vše nad tečkovanou
čarou představuje Aliciny akce a vše pod ní
představuje Bobovy akce.
Čas plyne zleva doprava jako vždy a vidíme, že začínáme
s těmito dvěma qubity, které jsou ve stavu Phi plus –
to je e-bit,
se kterým Alice a Bob začínají.
Qubity můžeme označit, abychom věděli, který je který – to je qubit A a toto je qubit
B, které tvoří e-bit,
a toto je qubit Q, který
Alice chce přenést Bobovi.
Zde předpokládáme, že
stav tohoto qubitu Q je Psi, ale o něco později se podíváme na možnost,
že Q je provázán
s nějakým jiným systémem. A co diagram tvrdí tím, že jsme napsali psi dole,
je to, že tento circuit
efektivně přenáší jakýkoli stav psi, který jsme měli
nahoře v Alicině části, dolů do Bobovy části –
jediná komunikace,
která překračuje
čáru mezi Alicí a Bobem, jsou dva klasické
bity představované těmito dvojitými čarami zde.
Trochu tento
diagram zmenšíme, abychom měli trochu více prostoru, a podívejme se na
circuit zblízka.
Počáteční podmínky jsem již popsal, ale jen pro rekapitulaci: Alice drží qubit A
a Bob drží qubit B,
přičemž A a B dohromady
jsou ve stavu Phi plus – to je tedy to, co znamená sdílet e-bit.
Alice má také tento qubit Q, který chce přenést Bobovi, a uvažujeme případ, že Q je v nějakém libovolném kvantovém stavu Psi.
Nevíme nic o tom,
jak se Alice a Bob dostali k tomuto e-bitu.
Možná ho mají
už dlouho – třeba ho vytvořili před nějakou dobou, když byli na stejném místě,
a šetřili si ho
na tuto příležitost, ale tyto detaily zde nejsou podstatné.
Kroky, které následují a představují
samotný protokol teleportace, jsou tyto – a jen pro upřesnění:
to jsou kroky, které
diagram popisuje, a my je jen
zapíšeme slovy, aby bylo jasné, co
diagram vyjadřuje.
Alice nejprve provede
operaci controlled-NOT, kde qubit Q, který
chce poslat Bobovi, je control a
qubit A je target.
Dalším krokem je, že
provede operaci Hadamard na Q, a poté změří
dva qubity, které drží,
A a Q, pomocí standardních bázových měření, přičemž necháme malé a označovat výsledek měření qubitu A,
WEBVTT
a malé b označovat výsledek měření qubitu Q.
Alice pak pošle
tyto dva klasické bity Bobovi – to je jediná komunikace v tomto protokolu, která je v diagramu naznačena
tím, že tyto dva
bity překračují tečkovanou čáru mezi Alicí a Bobem,
kterou si můžeš představit jako libovolnou
vzdálenost, která je odděluje.
Poté, co Bob obdrží bity
a a b, udělá dvě věci.
Zaprvé, pokud se a rovná jedné, provede operaci X,
jinými slovy NOT gate na svém qubitu B,
a pokud se a rovná nule, pak to neudělá.
Podobně,
pokud se b rovná jedné, Bob provede operaci Z
nebo Z-gate nebo fázový flip
také na qubitu b, a stejně jako dříve, pokud se b rovná nule, pak to neudělá.
To vše je naznačeno na obrázku, kde máme tyto controlled-X
a controlled-Z gate, jejichž controls jsou
dva klasické bity.
Tyto gate nemusíš chápat jako control gate,
pokud nechceš – je to jen praktický způsob,
jak vyjádřit, co chceme
ve formě diagramu circuit. Podstatou je, že Bob aplikuje
X-gate na qubit b, pokud se a rovná jedné, a pak aplikuje Z-gate
na qubit b, pokud se B rovná jedné.
Pro pohodlí si můžeme poté explicitně zapsat
kombinovanou operaci, kterou Bob provádí na svém qubitu b
v závislosti na klasických
bitech, které mu Alice posílá.
Takový je tedy protokol teleportace – je to vlastně docela jednoduché, skutečnost, že to skutečně funguje, je jiná věc, a přestože analýza
není nijak složitá,
neměl bys mít pocit, že ti něco uniklo, pokud hned nevidíš, proč to funguje.
Proto musíme
projít analýzou, a to uděláme jako další.
Abychom analyzovali protokol teleportace, projdeme ho krok za krokem a podíváme se, jaké jsou stavy tří qubitů v různých okamžicích.
Nejprve uvažujeme
případ, že vrchní qubit je ve stavu Alfa-nula plus beta-jedna, kde alfa a beta
jsou libovolná komplexní čísla,
která způsobují, že tento vektor
je jednotkový vektor.
Toto je qubit Q, který
Alice se snaží přenést, ale na pojmenování nám teď příliš nezáleží.
O něco později se
podíváme na situaci, kdy je tento qubit
provázán s jiným systémem, ale toto je dobrý výchozí
bod, abychom věci zjednodušili
a trochu jasněji ukázali, jak analýza
funguje.
Pokud uvažujeme stav
tří qubitů dohromady na začátku, vidíme,
že tento stav má tvar, který vidíš zde.
První dva qubity jsou
ve stavu Phi plus, třetí qubit je ten horní
podle konvence
pro řazení qubitů, kterou jsem
popsal v předchozí lekci, a tak bereme tenzorový součin, abychom dostali stav
tří qubitů dohromady.
Tento výraz můžeme rozvést
tak, že nejprve dosadíme definici stavu Phi plus a poté vypočítáme tenzorový součin
a dostaneme stav,
který vidíš zde.
Není to vždy nejlepší
strategie – úplně rozvinout vektor takto – obecně je dobré počkat, dokud k tomu
nemáš dobrý důvod.
Zde dobrý důvod máme: chceme
vypočítat působení tohoto controlled NOT gate a zápisem stavu v této formě
to lze velmi snadno udělat.
A konkrétně takový je
stav tří qubitů po aplikaci controlled NOT gate.
Třetí qubit je control qubit, protože je
nahoře podle naší konvence, a druhý qubit,
tedy prostřední,
je target, takže jednoduše
operujeme na stavech odpovídajícím způsobem – pokud je třetí bit
nula, nic se nestane,
a pokud je třetí bit jedna,
pak přehodíme druhý bit.
Poté provedeme Hadamard
gate na třetím qubitu, výsledný vektor můžeme zapsat tak, jak vidíš
zde, přičemž dosadíme
stav plus a stav minus za stav nula a stav jedna.
A pokud chceme mít dostatek
prostoru pro rozvedení, budeme ho muset trochu zmenšit a nyní dosazením stavů
plus a mínus
za jejich definice
a přesunutím odmocniny ze dvou do jmenovatele dostaneme stav, který vidíš zde.
A rozvedením dostaneme stav, který vidíš zde.
Takový je tedy stav tří qubitů poté, co Alice provede své dvě operace.
Alice pak měří
a pokud chceme analyzovat měření, izolujeme standardní bázové vektory
pro měřené systémy
tak, jak jsme o tom mluvili ve druhé lekci, a pokud to v tomto konkrétním případě uděláme, dostaneme toto.
A když se na tento výraz chvíli podíváš, může se zdát trochu zvláštní, protože nyní vypadá, jako by první qubit,
tedy spodní qubit,
nějak závisel na alfa a beta, přestože
v tomto okamžiku ještě neproběhla žádná komunikace přes tečkovanou čáru,
WEBVTT
ale to je jen iluze. Pamatuj, že skaláry se
volně pohybují skrze tenzorové součiny, takže ve skutečnosti alfa a beta
nejsou spojeny s prvním qubitem.
Vše, co jsme vlastně udělali,
je použití závorek v souladu s
multilinearitou tenzorových součinů.
Každopádně tato forma nám umožňuje vidět, co měření dělá, a hned si můžeme všimnout jedné
zajímavé věci:
pravděpodobnosti čtyř možných výsledků měření jsou vždy rovnoměrné.
Pravděpodobnost naměření každého
páru výsledků je jedna čtvrtina, takže zejména
neexistuje žádná závislost
na alfa a beta.
To vidíme v každém případě výpočtem druhé mocniny euklidovské normy
vektoru, který je v tenzorovém součinu se standardním bázovým
vektorem, který jsme izolovali,
a v každém případě dostaneme jednu čtvrtinu, kterou získáme umocněním jedné poloviny krát absolutní hodnota na druhou alfa
plus absolutní hodnota
na druhou beta, což je jedna, a tak v každém případě dostaneme jednu čtvrtinu.
Je skutečně důležité,
že pravděpodobnosti těchto různých výsledků nijak nezávisí na qubitu, který
Alice chce přenést.
Nemohlo by se stát, aby libovolný stav vstoupil nahoře, vyšel dole, a přitom měření odhalilo
informaci o tomto stavu.
Pokud chceš získat informaci o libovolném kvantovém stavu, obecně
budeš muset tento stav narušit.
Zde je tabulka, která popisuje nejen pravděpodobnosti
různých výsledků, ale také stav
tří qubitů dohromady
podmíněný každým možným
výsledkem měření.
Dostaneme ji normalizací vektorů v tenzorovém součinu s různými
standardními bázovými stavy, ale to je v tomto případě snadné –
stačí eliminovat faktor jedné poloviny, abychom dostali jednotkový vektor.
Takže bezprostředně
po Alicině měření má Alice dva rovnoměrně náhodné bity, nic víc.
Zejména už
nemá původní stav a nemá žádnou
informaci o něm – má jen náhodné bity.
Bobův stav nyní
závisí na alfa a beta i na výsledcích měření.
Kdybychom si na chvíli představili,
že Alice ještě neposlala výsledky měření
a Bob tedy neví, jaké jsou výsledky měření,
nebyl by schopen
získat žádnou informaci o alfa a beta
měřením svého qubitu.
Tyto čtyři možnosti,
které zde máme, jsou dostatečně zamíchané, aby bylo zaručeno, že žádnou informaci
o alfa a beta
nelze měřením
nikdy získat. To musí být pravda na intuitivní úrovni, protože jinak bychom měli
komunikaci rychlejší než světlo.
Alice rozhodně nemůže
přenést informaci Bobovi, aniž by mu cokoli poslala, ale samozřejmě Alice výsledky měření
Bobovi posílá, takže rozšiřme tabulku, abychom viděli, co se stane, když
Bob provede své operace.
V tomto sloupci zde máme různé operace, které Bob efektivně provádí pro každý z možných
výsledků měření
jak jsme pozorovali dříve,
a pokud projdeme jeden po druhém a aplikujeme tuto
operaci na Bobův qubit – což je ten první, B –
vidíme, že ve všech čtyřech případech dostaneme
stejný výsledek a tím výsledkem je původní stav.
Původní stav qubitu Q byl tedy úspěšně teleportován do B.
Pokud Bob chce svůj qubit přejmenovat a nazývat ho Q, může to samozřejmě udělat, ale podstatné je, že teď
drží původní stav,
který měla Alice, a samozřejmě ze zřejmých důvodů ho Alice nemá.
Všimni si také, že e-bit
byl tímto procesem efektivně spotřebován –
teleportace má svou cenu
a tou cenou je jeden e-bit a dva klasické bity komunikace, přičemž po skončení protokolu e-bit zmizí.
Nyní jsme tedy prokázali, že
protokol teleportace funguje správně za předpokladu, že vrchní qubit je v kvantovém stavu
tvaru alfa krát ket
nula plus beta krát ket jedna.
Co se ale stane, pokud je
vrchní qubit provázán s nějakým jiným systémem, například
s jedním z našich dalších qubitů
jak máme zde na obrazovce? Možná bychom chtěli použít teleportaci
za těchto okolností.
Možná Alice a Bob skutečně
plánují provést teleportaci 100krát, aby Alice mohla přenést
100qubitový kvantový registr
Bobovi, po jednom qubitu.
Nebo možná tyto další
qubity nejsou vůbec v Alicině držení
a někdo jiný je má – třeba Alice ani
neví, že existují.
Otázka zní: funguje
teleportace stále i v případě, kdy teleportovaný qubit je provázán s jiným systémem?
Stav qubitu Q spolu s dalším
systémem, který uvažujeme, je zde vyjádřen tak, jak vidíš nahoře
kde gamma nula a
gamma jedna jsou jednotkové vektory představující kvantové stavy
tohoto dalšího systému.
Libovolný stav kombinovaného systému lze vždy zapsat tímto způsobem.
Vlastně alfa a beta
ani nepotřebujeme, ale pokud je zahrneme,
pak můžeme vzít gamma nula a gamma jedna jako jednotkové vektory
a to usnadní
propojení s jednodušším případem, který jsme již uvažovali.
WEBVTT
Můžeme provést
podobnou analýzu jako tu, kterou jsme již provedli, ale kde také sledujeme
tento dodatečný systém.
Je to trochu složitější, protože máme další systém, ale
myšlenka je přesně stejná – zde je velmi stručné shrnutí.
Toto je počáteční stav, toto je stav po
controlled NOT gate,
a toto je stav po
operaci Hadamard.
Pokud toto rozvineme,
můžeme tento stav vyjádřit tak, jak vidíš zde,
to je stav bezprostředně
před Aliciným měřením, a pokud projdeme
možnosti stejně jako dříve
a zvážíme, co
se stane, když Bob aplikuje operaci, kterou má aplikovat,
zjistíme, že
skutečně vychází správný stav a protokol funguje podle očekávání.
V této tabulce mimochodem používáme písmeno R
k označení tohoto dodatečného systému, a vidíš, že používáme poměrně jednoduchý trik:
rozhodli jsme se, že chceme, alespoň momentálně, řadit
systémy jako B, R, A, Q,
protože to je pohodlnější pro zápis stavů zde.
Podle diagramu by systémy měly být
řazeny jako B, A, Q, R,
ale pokud to jasně uvedeme, můžeme zvolit jiné
pořadí, které je pohodlnější.
Stručně řečeno, vše, co se v této analýze děje, je
stejné jako v jednodušší analýze,
ale náhodou máme
tyto další vektory, gamma nula a gamma jedna,
které jednoduše jedou s proudem.
Vždy máme gamma nula
když je tam faktor alfa, a gamma jedna, když
je tam faktor beta, a na konci se vše správně sejde.
To vlastně vůbec nepřekvapuje – máme fyzický proces, který se chová jako operace identity
na qubitu
v libovolném kvantovém stavu, a existuje pouze
jeden způsob, jak to může nastat, a sice že operace
je operace identity.
To je trochu snazší vysvětlit pomocí obecné formulace
kvantových informací, ale podstatné je, že na základě linearity
jsme tuto dodatečnou analýzu vlastně vůbec nepotřebovali provádět.
Jakmile víme, že
teleportace funguje správně pro jeden qubit v izolaci, můžeme uzavřít, že existuje
jediná možná věc,
která popisuje, co protokol dělá, a sice to, že implementuje
operaci identity, kde qubit vstupuje zde
a vychází zde, efektivně fungující jako dokonalý
bezšumový kvantový kanál.
Jen několik rychlých poznámek
o teleportaci, než přejdeme k
druhému příkladu lekce – superdense coding.
Zaprvé si myslím, že je důležité objasnit, že teleportace není aplikací kvantových informací – je to protokol
a konkrétně jde o
protokol pro provádění kvantové komunikace.
Aby teleportace,
jak jsem ji popsal, byla užitečná, musí existovat nějaký důvod k provádění kvantové komunikace.
Zadruhé, je rozumné spekulovat, že teleportace by jednou mohla být standardním způsobem
komunikace kvantových informací, a konkrétně proces známý jako destilace provázanosti
by mohl být potenciálně použit
jako způsob spolehlivé komunikace qubitů. Pokud Alice a Bob vědí, že budou komunikovat kvantové informace nebo potřebují komunikovat
kvantové informace, pak by tento proces destilace provázanosti
mohl být použit k přeměně většího počtu zašuměných e-bitů
na menší počet
vysoce kvalitních e-bitů, které by pak mohly být použity pro bezšumovou nebo téměř bezšumovou teleportaci.
Myšlenka je taková, že proces
destilace provázanosti je v jistém smyslu méně choulostivý – mohli bychom přijmout ztráty a
pokud to nevyjde,
prostě to zkusíme znovu, zatímco samotné qubity,
které chceme přenést, by mohly být považovány za mnohem cennější.
To je samozřejmě spekulace, ale podstatné je, že není těžké hypotetizovat situace,
ve kterých by teleportace
mohla být velmi praktickým
způsobem komunikace qubitů.
A poslední poznámka
o teleportaci: myšlenka stojící za teleportací a způsob, jakým funguje,
je zcela zásadní
v kvantových informacích a výpočtech – teleportace je skutečně základním kamenem teorie kvantových informací a různé variace
na tuto myšlenku se také často
vyskytují – jen jako jeden příklad: existují návrhy
na implementaci různých quantum gate
pomocí teleportace, ale
kde jsou zvoleny různé počáteční stavy a měření tak, aby výsledkem
bylo aplikování zvolené operace
spíše než komunikace.
Dalším příkladem je superdense coding.
Stejně jako kvantová teleportace
je superdense coding protokolem, a to, čeho dosahuje, je komplementární k teleportaci.
Zatímco teleportace umožňuje
přenést jeden qubit pomocí e-bitu a dvou
klasických bitů komunikace,
superdense coding umožňuje
přenést dva klasické bity pomocí
e-bitu a jednoho qubitu kvantové komunikace.
Stručně řečeno, superdense coding umožňuje přenos
klasických informací, a důvod, proč se nazývá superdense coding,
WEBVTT
je to, že umožňuje zakódovat dva
klasické bity komunikace do jediného qubitu,
ale musíme za to zaplatit
jedním e-bitem.
Zde je přesnější
vysvětlení nastavení.
Opět máme Alici a Boba, kde Alice je odesílatel
a Bob je příjemce, přičemž tentokrát má Alice dva klasické bity,
které chce poslat Bobovi.
Alice může Bobovi poslat jeden qubit a Alice a Bob sdílejí
e-bit, který mohou použít k splnění svého úkolu –
tedy aby Bob dostal
ty dva klasické bity.
Tento úkol se může zdát méně zajímavý než úkol, který splňuje
teleportace,
zejména pokud se domníváme,
že posílat qubity je podstatně
obtížnější nebo náročnější než posílat klasické bity –
to je docela rozumný pohled, ale je to rozhodně zajímavé, že je to vůbec možné.
Jedním z důvodů, proč je to zajímavé,
je to, že je skutečně nemožné splnit
tento úkol přenosu dvou klasických bitů informace
pomocí jediného qubitu, aniž bychom
využili e-bit.
Víme to díky slavnému teorému, který se nazývá Holevův teorém.
Holevův teorém
je obecnější a přesné znění
Holevova teorému je trochu technické a vyžaduje nějaké vysvětlení,
ale jedním z jeho důsledků
je, že nelze přenést libovolný počet klasických
bitů komunikace pomocí menšího počtu qubitů
kvantové komunikace samotné.
Pokud chceš spolehlivě přenést dva klasické bity
informace pomocí qubitů a nemáš
e-bit k dispozici,
budeš muset poslat dva qubity, takže bys je také mohl přímo použít k uložení bitů, které chceš přenést.
Dalším důvodem, proč je superdense
coding zajímavý, je těsný
komplementární vztah, který má s teleportací, a k tomu se vrátíme
za chvíli. Zde je popis protokolu superdense coding pomocí quantum circuit.
Pro tento případ
nebudu vypisovat všechny kroky, ale budeme se držet pouze popisu pomocí diagramu circuit.
Jak vidíš, opět
máme Alici a Boba, kde Alice je nahoře
a Bob je dole.
Toto je e-bit,
který je zpočátku sdílen mezi Alicí a Bobem a byl nějak vytvořen před spuštěním protokolu.
Alice má dva klasické bity, A a B, které vidíš nahoře, a prostřednictvím protokolu, který circuit popisuje,
tyto dva klasické bity
skončí v Bobových rukou.
Přes čáru mezi Alicí a Bobem prochází
pouze jeden qubit, a samozřejmě nejsou posílány
žádné klasické bity –
přenos
dvou klasických bitů je přece cílem protokolu.
Všimneš si také, že používá
přesně stejné komponenty jako teleportace – máme controlled NOT
gate, Hadamard gate,
a Z a X-gate
řízené klasickými bity.
Jsou ale uspořádány jinak, takže pojďme na analýzu, abychom viděli, jak to funguje.
Abychom analyzovali, jak superdense coding funguje, začneme zápisem
Bellovy báze, která je samotným jádrem analýzy.
Nejprve se podíváme na efekt Aliciných akcí
na stav Phi plus, a uvidíme, že Alice transformuje
stav Phi plus na jeden
ze čtyř Bellových stavů v závislosti na bitech,
které chce poslat.
Zapišme tabulku, abychom
mohli sledovat, co se děje.
Zaprvé, pokud jsou A i B nula, pak se neaplikuje ani Z-gate ani
X-gate, takže Aliciny akce nic nedělají –
jinými slovy Phi
plus se zobrazí na Phi plus.
Můžeme to také vyjádřit jako rovnici, jak vidíš zde –
na Alicin qubit se nic nestane a na Bobův qubit se nic nestane,
přičemž nedělání ničeho je reprezentováno
maticí identity.
Co se stane, pokud se A rovná nule a B rovná jedné?
Protože se B rovná jedné, aplikujeme Z-gate a
neaplikujeme X-gate, protože se A rovná nule,
a vidíme, že celkový efekt je, že Alice provede Z-gate.
Alice je na pravé straně,
protože je nahoře, i když by to
v tomto konkrétním
případě vlastně na ničem nezáleželo – efektem je
že stav Phi plus se
zobrazí na Phi mínus, což můžeš odhadnout pohledem
z těchto výrazů, pokud si pamatuješ, jak Z-gate funguje.
Přidáme tento případ do tabulky, zbývají dva další případy: pokud se A rovná jedné
a B rovná nule,
pak Alice provede
X-gate, který transformuje Phi plus na Chi plus, a pokud se A rovná jedné
a B rovná jedné,
pak Alice provede nejprve Z, pak
X a dostaneme Chi mínus.
Naše tabulka nám tedy říká, co se stane ve čtyřech možných případech, a to je, že Alice efektivně volí, který
WEBVTT
ze čtyř Bellových stavů chce sdílet s Bobem, přičemž má svobodu volby tím, že operuje jen na svém qubitu
a to je poměrně zajímavý
aspekt provázanosti.
Alice pak pošle svůj qubit
Bobovi – v tomto okamžiku Bob drží jeden ze čtyř Bellových stavů a potřebuje jen
zjistit, který to je,
aby bity zpět odkódoval.
Můžeme ověřit, že
controlled NOT gate následovaný Hadamard gate
jak máme v diagramu, udělá správnou věc.
Nepůjdu do detailů, ale pokud to uděláš, zjistíš, že efekt je
takový, jak vidíš v tabulce.
Jedním ze způsobů, jak to ověřit,
je jednoduše výpočet. Případně si uvědomíme, že jsme toto
vlastně již prošli v opačném směru
v předchozí lekci. V předchozí lekci jsme
měli nejprve Hadamard gate a poté controlled NOT gate
a viděli jsme, že tento circuit
zobrazoval standardní bázové stavy na Bellovy stavy s nepříjemným
znaménkem mínus v jednom z případů.
Pokud obrátíme pořadí gate a uvážíme skutečnost,
že oba tyto dva gate jsou svými vlastními inverzy,
dostaneme inverz,
takže v tomto
případě akce probíhá v opačném směru
a znaménko mínus si může vybrat, na které
straně chce být –
jinak je na svém místě, a v tomto okamžiku je okamžitě jasné, že měření odhalí správné hodnoty –
znaménko mínus nám zde nedělá problémy, protože jedna se vyskytuje s pravděpodobností jedna v tomto případě, a to je vše, co k analýze je.
Stručně: Alice vybere Bellův stav a Bob zjistí, který to je.
Jen pár stručných poznámek
o superdense coding, než přejdeme dál: zaprvé bychom měli uznat, že superdense coding
pravděpodobně nebude
užitečný ani praktický v žádném smyslu jako prostředek
přenosu klasických informací.
Klasická komunikace
je velmi levná a fyzické posílání qubitů je přinejmenším náročné,
a dokud to bude platit, od superdense coding bychom neočekávali
žádnou praktickou výhodu.
Ale to, že pravděpodobně nebude praktický, neznamená, že superdense
coding není zajímavý.
Je ve skutečnosti velmi zajímavý – zaprvé, základní myšlenka je
skutečně zcela zásadní,
a když říkám základní myšlenka, mám na mysli myšlenku, že pokud Alice
sdílí Bellův stav s Bobem,
pak si může sama změnit tento stav na jakýkoli jiný Bellův stav,
který si přeje – nepotřebuje k tomu Bobovu
pomoc vůbec.
Toto je konkrétní příklad
týkající se Bellových stavů, ale za ním stojí obecnější myšlenka o svobodě, kterou má jeden hráč
transformovat provázaný stav sdílený s jiným hráčem, a přesné pochopení toho, jaká tato svoboda je,
je důležitým krokem v porozumění kvantovým informacím, a přesně jak tuto svobodu popsat jednoduše
a elegantně uvidíme
ve třetí části série.
Superdense coding také
poskytuje konkrétní příklad toho, co lze s provázaností dělat, a sice umožnit přenos dvou klasických
bitů
posláním jediného qubitu. Jak jsem již zmínil, toto
je provitelně nemožné bez provázanosti, jak říká Holevův teorém.
Můžeme také uvažovat teleportaci a superdense coding dohromady a vidíme, že zakládají ekvivalenci
mezi jedním qubitem kvantové komunikace a dvěma bity klasické komunikace.
Dokud jsi ochoten
utratit jeden e-bit, lze efektivně
převést jedno na druhé.
Teleportace umožňuje
komunikaci jednoho qubitu pomocí dvou klasických bitů komunikace a superdense coding jde opačným směrem
a umožňuje přenos dvou klasických
bitů komunikace pomocí jednoho qubitu kvantové komunikace.
Bez utracení e-bitu
však nelze jedno převést na druhé – je to provázanost, která to umožňuje.
Třetím a posledním příkladem,
který v této lekci probereme, není protokol, ale
hra zvaná CHSH game.
Když v tomto kontextu mluvíme o hře, nemyslíme tím něco, co je určeno
k hraní pro zábavu nebo sport –
jde spíše o matematickou abstrakci ve smyslu teorie her.
Matematické abstrakce her jsou velmi hojně studovány v
ekonomii a informatice, a v abstrakci se skrývá
značná hodnota,
takže hry nejsou jen o zábavě,
jak se ukazuje,
i když je zábavné o nich přemýšlet.
V tomto konkrétním případě máme v podstatě
myšlenkový experiment, který lze popsat
poměrně intuitivně jako hru.
Písmena CHSH odkazují na autory – Johna Clausera, Michaela
Horna, Abnera Shimonyho a Richarda Holta – článku z roku 1969, kde byl příklad
poprvé popsán. Oni ho jako hru nepopsali
a je docela běžné označovat tento příklad
ne jako CHSH game, ale
spíše jako CHSH inequality.
Pro informatika, jako jsem já, je ale přirozené
ho popisovat jako hru.
Již jsem naznačil, že
matematické abstrakce her jsou důležité i užitečné, přičemž existuje mnoho různých
kategorií her,
WEBVTT
které lze uvažovat. CHSH game je
příkladem třídy her zvané nelokální hry.
Zde je obecné nastavení
nelokální hry.
Máme dva hráče, Alici a Boba, kteří spolupracují jako tým, takže buď vyhrají spolu,
nebo prohrají spolu.
To znamená, že nemají
žádný podnět k sobeckému jednání, takže jde v podstatě o opačný extrém k hrám s nulovým součtem,
které jsou čistě konkurenční – zde je hra čistě kooperativní.
Existuje třetí entita nazývaná rozhodčí.
Rozhodčí není hráčem ve hře, ale spíše hru řídí, a vlastně si můžeš specifikaci
konkrétní instance
nelokální hry a specifikaci
rozhodčího představit jako ekvivalentní.
Na Alici a Boba je uvaleno kriticky důležité omezení: jakmile hra začne, je jim zakázáno komunikovat spolu navzájem.
Mohou se předem domluvit
na jakékoli strategii, ale žádná komunikace
není povolena mezi nimi během samotné hry.
Pokud chceš, můžeš si představit,
že hra probíhá v jakémsi bezpečném zařízení, jako by rozhodčí hrál
roli detektiva
a Alice a Bob jsou podezřelí umístění v různých
místnostech policejní stanice, ale jiný způsob, jak přemýšlet o nastavení,
je, že Alice a Bob jsou
odděleni obrovskou vzdáleností a komunikace je zakázána, protože rychlost světla
neumožňuje komunikaci
dost rychle. Pokud by se Alice pokusila poslat zprávu Bobovi, hra by skončila dřív,
než by ji Bob dostal.
Způsob, jakým nelokální hra
funguje, je, že nejprve rozhodčí položí Alici i Bobovi otázku.
Alicina otázka je označena X a Bobova otázka je označena Y.
Obecně si X a Y můžeš představit jako klasické stavy
z jakýchkoli klasických stavů, a v konkrétním případě CHSH game
jsou X a Y bity.
Alice a Bob musí poté poskytnout odpovědi – Alicina odpověď je označena A
a Bobova odpověď je označena B,
přičemž tyto odpovědi lze opět obecně chápat jako klasické stavy, a stejně jako otázky, budou to v CHSH game bity.
V tomto okamžiku
rozhodčí rozhodne – Alice a Bob buď vyhrají nebo prohrají podle toho, zda
pár odpovědí A, B
je správný pro
pár otázek X, Y, které rozhodčí položil, a k tomu se za chvíli ještě vrátím.
Nejprve se podívejme blíže na rozhodčího, abychom pochopili, co je pro Alici a Boba v nelokální hře potenciálně náročné.
Co dělá
nelokální hru potenciálně náročnou, je to, že rozhodčí může použít náhodnost k volbě otázek X a Y.
To znamená, že Alice
a Bob mají nejistotu – předem nevědí, jaká otázka jim bude položena, a snad ještě důležitěji,
nevědí, jakou otázku
dostal ten druhý, a právě tato nejistota
spolu se skutečností, že nemohou komunikovat,
představuje výzvu.
Je to tedy podobná situace jako když detektiv
vyslýchá dva podezřelé v různých místnostech – pokud podezřelí nevědí,
jaké otázky jsou kladeny tomu druhému, je pro ně mnohem těžší, pokud jsou vinní, udržet si konzistentní výpověď.
Zmínil jsem před chvílí, že rozhodčí rozhodne,
zda Alice a Bob odpověděli
správně nebo nesprávně
v závislosti na otázkách,
které dostali.
Předpokládá se, že toto
rozhodnutí je učiněno podle nějakého pevného
pravidla, přičemž si můžeš zvolit jakékoli pravidlo,
ale předpokládá se, že Alice
a Bob pravidlo znají, takže mají alespoň šanci odpovědět správně.
Za chvíli se podíváme na
pravidlo pro CHSH game, ale mohli bychom zvážit jiné pravidlo a měli bychom jiný
příklad nelokální hry.
Některé nelokální hry jsou zajímavé a ve skutečnosti některé jsou docela fascinující a záhadné dodnes,
a některé nejsou tak zajímavé –
to je prostě povaha
modelu nelokálních her.
V každém případě toto jsou dvě různé věci, které jsou potřeba k popisu rozhodčího: jak přesně jsou otázky vybírány
a které páry odpovědí jsou správné pro každý možný pár otázek.
Pokud máme popis
těchto dvou věcí, pak máme popis rozhodčího a to efektivně popisuje
instanci nelokální hry.
Podívejme se nyní konkrétně na
CHSH game.
Způsob, jakým je hra
definována – nebo ekvivalentně, jak je definován rozhodčí – je následující:
zaprvé, jak jsem již zmínil, otázky i odpovědi jsou bity, takže rozhodčí posílá bit X
Alici a bit Y Bobovi,
přičemž každý z nich odpoví bitem: Alice odpoví A
a Bob odpoví B.
Způsob, jakým rozhodčí volí
otázky, je jednoduchý – volí je
rovnoměrně náhodně,
takže pár otázek X, Y má stejnou pravděpodobnost být jakýmkoli
ze čtyř možností: nula, nula; nula, jedna;
jedna, nula a jedna, jedna.
Konečně pravidlo, které
určuje, které odpovědi vyhrají a které prohrají, je: pár odpovědí A, B je správný pro pár otázek X, Y
WEBVTT
právě tehdy, když se exkluzivní nebo A a B rovná logickému a X a Y.
To může být trochu snazší vstřebat, pokud tyto podmínky
vyjádříme ve formě tabulky, jak vidíš zde.
V prvním sloupci máme čtyři možné páry otázek a ve druhém sloupci máme podmínky na A a B,
které jsou vyžadovány,
aby Alice a Bob vyhráli.
V prvních třech případech
je a Y nula, takže exkluzivní nebo musí být rovno nule,
aby vyhráli,
a to je totéž jako říci, že A a B musí být stejné, protože A a B jsou bity, přičemž ve čtvrtém případě
je a X a Y rovno
jedné, takže exkluzivní nebo A a B musí být rovno jedné, aby Alice a Bob vyhráli,
a to je totéž
jako říci, že A a B musí být různé.
Takový je tedy CHSH game, a nyní si můžeme myslet na
různé možné strategie pro Alici a Boba a jak dobře mohou v této hře uspět.
Začneme přemýšlením o
deterministických strategiích, kde Alicina odpověď A je
funkcí otázky X, kterou dostane, a
podobně Bobova odpověď B
je funkcí
otázky Y, kterou dostane.
Ukáže se, že žádná
deterministická strategie nemůže vyhrávat pokaždé.
Jedním ze způsobů, jak to odůvodnit, je
jednoduše projít jeden po druhém všechny možné
deterministické strategie a ověřit, že každá z nich prohraje
alespoň pro jeden ze čtyř
možných párů otázek.
Alice a Bob mají
každý čtyři možné funkce, ze kterých si mohou vybrat – viděli jsme tyto
čtyři funkce v první lekci, takže celkem je 16 možností k ověření.
Jiný způsob, jak to vidět, je
přemýšlet o rovnicích zde na obrazovce – přemýšlíme
o deterministických strategiích,
kde A a B jsou funkce
X a Y.
Například A nula
představuje Alicinu odpověď, když je její otázka X rovna nule, a A jedna představuje Alicinu odpověď,
když je její otázka X rovna jedné.
To jsou čtyři rovnice,
které musí platit, aby byly splněny podmínky vítězství v každém ze čtyř případů.
Například, pokud se X rovná
nule a Y rovná nule, pak exkluzivní nebo A
a B musí být rovno nule,
zatímco v případě, že se X rovná jedné a Y rovná jedné,
exkluzivní nebo A a B musí být rovno jedné.
Jedním ze způsobů, jak vidět, že neexistuje způsob, jak zvolit funkce A a B tak,
aby všechny tyto rovnice platily, je jednoduše vzít exkluzivní nebo všech rovnic.
Exkluzivní nebo libovolné
binární hodnoty se sebou samou je rovno nule, takže z toho plyne, že exkluzivní nebo
levých stran
je rovno nule – to je proto,
že máme dvě instance A nula, dvě instance A jedna,
dvě instance B nula
a dvě instance B jedna.
Takže exkluzivní nebo všech
dává nám výsledek nula, ale pokud vezmeme exkluzivní nebo pravých stran rovnic,
dostaneme jednu, nikoli nulu. Takže čtyři rovnice nemohou všechny platit – alespoň jedna z nich musí být nepravdivá,
a to povede k prohře
pro Alici a Boba v alespoň jednom ze čtyř případů.
Z toho plyne, protože rozhodčí volí otázky
rovnoměrně, že pravděpodobnost výhry Alice a Boba při použití deterministické strategie
je nejvýše tři čtvrtiny neboli 75 %.
Skutečnost, že Alice a Bob mohou vyhrát s pravděpodobností tři čtvrtiny, je vlastně docela snadno vidět:
pokud Alice a Bob oba odpoví vždy nula,
budou správně
tři ze čtyř případů.
Takže Alice a Bob nemohou
dosáhnout nic lepšího než výhra 75 % času při použití
deterministické strategie.
Co ale pravděpodobnostní strategie?
Ukazuje se, že použití
pravděpodobnostní strategie jim vůbec nepomůže, protože každou
pravděpodobnostní strategii
lze alternativně chápat
jako náhodný výběr deterministické strategie, stejně jako pravděpodobnostní
operace lze chápat
jako náhodné výběry
deterministických operací, jak jsme viděli v první lekci.
Průměr nikdy není
větší než maximum, takže z toho plyne, že pravděpodobnostní strategie nenabízí žádnou výhodu
z hlediska výhry
oproti deterministické strategii. To zahrnuje i možnost, že náhodné
volby Alice a Boba jsou korelované.
Závěrem je tedy, že výhra s pravděpodobností tří čtvrtin je to nejlepší, co Alice
a Bob mohou dosáhnout při jakékoli klasické strategii,
ať už deterministické
nebo pravděpodobnostní.
Přirozená otázka, která se nabízí, je, zda Alice a Bob mohou dosáhnout lepšího výsledku pomocí kvantové strategie, a konkrétně
pokud sdílejí provázaný kvantový stav, který si mohli připravit
před hraním hry, může jim to pomoci?
Odpověď je ano, může, a to je podstatou příkladu a proto je tak zajímavý.
Podívejme se tedy přesně na to, jak mohou Alice a Bob v této hře dosáhnout lepšího výsledku pomocí provázanosti.
WEBVTT
Nejprve musíme definovat vektor kvantového stavu Chi
theta pro každý úhel theta, jak vidíš zde na obrazovce.
Chi theta se tedy rovná
cosinus theta krát ket nula plus sinus theta krát ket
jedna, přičemž zde
uvažujeme
úhly v radiánech.
Například tady je vektor, který dostaneme, když theta je rovno pí nad
čtyři, což je 45 stupňů.
Cosinus pí nad čtyři
a sinus pí nad čtyři jsou oba rovny jedné přes
odmocnina ze dvou, takže je to jen jiný
název pro stav plus.
Zde je další příklad, když theta je rovno třem krát pí nad osm – a pro případ, že neznáš
sinus a cosinus třech krát pí nad osm zpaměti,
zde je tabulka sinusů a cosinusů, které
budeme skutečně potřebovat
v průběhu tohoto příkladu,
a obsahuje ty, které potřebujeme pro tento konkrétní vektor.
Nyní, pokud chceme vzít skalární součin mezi libovolnými dvěma z těchto vektorů
pro úhly, řekněme alfa a beta, je to
přímočaré.
Máme jen reálné
záznamy v těchto vektorech, takže se nemusíme starat o komplexní sdružení, a dostaneme součin cosinusů
plus součin sinusů, přičemž můžeme použít jeden z
takzvaných vzorců pro sčítání úhlů
pro zjednodušení – jde o
cosinus rozdílu úhlů, a protože funkce cosinus
je symetrická kolem nuly,
nezáleží vlastně na tom, v jakém pořadí je vezmeme.
Pokud tyhle trigonometrické identity
nemáš v paměti,
mimochodem, nejsi sám, ale nemusíš si je pamatovat –
stačí je vyhledat. Tato dává smysl, pokud uvažuješ o geometrické interpretaci skalárního součinu
mezi reálnými jednotkovými vektory jako cosinus úhlu mezi nimi.
Pokud vypočítáme skalární součin tenzorového součinu libovolných dvou z těchto vektorů
se stavem Phi plus, dostaneme podobně vypadající výraz,
jen s odmocninou ze dvou
ve jmenovateli.
Toto je poprvé,
co se stav Phi plus objevuje v kontextu
tohoto příkladu, a za chvíli přesně uvidíme, proč nás
tento konkrétní skalární součin zajímá, ale zatím
si jen všimněme, že dostaneme stejný výraz, který jsme měli
pro skalární součin, děleno odmocninou ze dvou, takže můžeme zjednodušit jako dříve.
Dále definujeme
unitární matici, U theta, pro každý úhel theta,
jak vidíš zde –
není obtížné
ověřit, že jde skutečně o unitární matici.
Klíčová věc, kterou potřebujeme
rozpoznat, je, že vektor si theta je kolmý na
vektor si theta plus pí nad dvě, a to dává smysl,
protože pokud otočíme o pí nad dvě, tedy o 90 stupňů, dostaneme kolmý vektor.
Pokud poté vynásobíme U
theta a U theta dagger, dostaneme matici identity.
Intuitivně řečeno,
co tato matice dělá jako operace: zobrazuje si theta na ket nula a si theta plus pí dvě na ket jedna.
V tuto chvíli máme
vše potřebné k popisu strategie Alice a Boba.
Zaprvé, stejně jako u teleportace a superdense coding, Alice a Bob začnou sdílením e-bitu.
Alice drží qubit A,
Bob drží qubit B, přičemž oba qubity dohromady
jsou ve stavu Phi plus.
Aliciny akce jsou následující: dívá se na bit X, který
dostane od rozhodčího,
a pokud se X rovná nule,
provede U nula na A, což je vlastně totéž jako nedělat nic, protože U nula je matice identity,
zatímco pokud se X rovná jedné, aplikuje U pí nad čtyři na A.
Poté, co aplikuje
jednu ze dvou operací, změří A pomocí
standardního bázového měření a pošle výsledek
rozhodčímu.
Bob dělá něco velmi podobného – jeho qubit se samozřejmě nazývá B a dostává Y od
rozhodčího místo X –
klíčový rozdíl je
ale ten, že pro své unitární operace používá jiné úhly.
Pokud se Y rovná nule, aplikuje
U pí nad osm, a pokud se Y rovná jedné, aplikuje U záporné pí nad osm.
Za chvíli uvidíme, proč jsou tyto volby úhlů dobrou volbou –
vůbec to není zřejmé.
A zde je diagram circuit,
který vyjadřuje tuto strategii.
Bob je tentokrát nahoře a Alice
je dole, toto je e-bit, který vstupuje
a toto jsou unitární
gate, které Alice a Bob mohou nebo nemusí aplikovat
v závislosti na tom, jaká jsou X a Y.
Pro tento a tento gate máme gate, které jsou řízeny buď bitem X nebo bitem Y,
a pro tyto dva zde máme něco, co vypadá jako control gate, jenže kruh není vyplněný.
To znamená,
že pokud je control bit nastaven na nulu, gate se provede, a pokud je control nastaven na
jednu, nic se nestane.
Jde tedy jen o
obyčejný control gate, ale s tím, že role nuly a jedné pro control jsou prohozeny.
Efektivně tedy Bob
provede tento gate, pokud se Y rovná nule, a provede tento gate
WEBVTT
pokud se Y rovná jedné, a podobně Alice provede tento gate,
pokud se X rovná nule, a tento gate,
pokud se X rovná jedné.
To je tedy strategie Alice a Boba, a teď stačí
zjistit, jak dobře funguje.
Pro analýzu kvantové strategie, kterou jsem právě popsal, potřebujeme v tuto chvíli skutečně jen dvě věci: zaprvé unitární matici U Theta,
jak vidíš zde, a
zadruhé tento vzorec.
Definici vektoru si theta vlastně již ani nepotřebujeme – tyto dvě rovnice jsou vše, co potřebujeme.
Jsou čtyři případy,
které je třeba zvážit, počínaje případem jedna, kdy se X rovná
nule a Y rovná nule.
Pokud se vrátíme ke strategii, zjistíme, že v tomto
případě Alice provede U nula na svém qubitu a Bob provede
U pí nad osm na svém qubitu.
Pamatuj, Alice je
dole a Bob je nahoře, takže stav, který obdrží, vypadá takto.
A rozvedením podle definice U theta dostaneme tento
výraz, který vidíš zde.
Nemusíme to
dále rozvádět, protože nám k tomu pomůže druhý
vzorec.
A pokud tento vzorec aplikujeme
pro každý ze čtyř členů, dostaneme toto.
V tuto chvíli Alice a Bob oba měří a tato tabulka
vysvětluje rozdělení výsledků.
Vezmeme absolutní hodnotu
na druhou koeficientů, abychom dostali pravděpodobnosti, což se rovná
druhým mocninám koeficientů,
protože koeficienty jsou
v tomto případě všechna reálná čísla.
Pokud využijeme
hodnoty sinusů a cosinusů z dřívějška lekce
spolu s nějakými symetriemi, můžeme vyjádřit tyto pravděpodobnosti tak, jak máme zde
v posledním sloupci.
Nyní, to, co nás skutečně zajímá,
je pravděpodobnost, že vyhrají, a pamatuj, v případě, že X a Y jsou oba nula,
vyhrají, pokud jsou A a B stejné, a prohrají, pokud A a B nejsou stejné.
Pokud tyto pravděpodobnosti vypočítáme, zjistíme, že pravděpodobnost
toho, že A a B jsou stejné, je součet tohoto čísla a tohoto čísla,
což se rovná dvě plus
odmocnina ze dvou, to vše vydělené čtyřmi, což je přibližně 85 %.
Pravděpodobnost, že A a B nejsou stejné, je dvě mínus odmocnina ze dvou vydělená čtyřmi, což je přirozeně jedna mínus tato hodnota,
takže
vyhrají s pravděpodobností přibližně 85 % v tomto případě.
Zbývají tři další případy k uvažování, ale jsou všechny velmi podobné tomuto,
v případě, že se X rovná
nule a Y rovná jedné, Bob aplikuje U záporné pí nad osm místo U pí nad osm,
hodnoty ve
vzorcích se poněkud změní, ale nakonec dostaneme přesně
stejné pravděpodobnosti jako v předchozím případě.
Když se X rovná nule a Y rovná jedné, Alice a Bob stále vyhrávají,
když jsou A a B stejné, a tak máme přesně stejnou pravděpodobnost výhry
jako dříve.
Ve třetím případě, když se X rovná jedné a Y rovná nule, máme podobnou situaci – úhly jsou jiné,
ale mají přesně
stejný vzájemný vztah,
a ve skutečnosti dostaneme přesně
stejný vektor jako v předchozím případě.
Pravděpodobnosti jsou tedy stejné a stejná je i pravděpodobnost výhry.
Poslední případ je trochu
odlišný, jak bychom mohli očekávat, protože podmínka vítězství
je v tomto případě jiná.
Když jsou X a Y oba rovny jedné, Alice a Bob vyhrají, když
A a B jsou různé.
Základní metoda je stejná, i když jsou úhly jiné – tentokrát dostaneme tento vektor zde
a to můžeš ověřit provedením požadovaných odečtení.
Pravděpodobnosti se konečně mění, a pokud vyhledáme hodnoty, které potřebujeme, vidíme, že pravděpodobnosti efektivně
prohozeny oproti dříve, takže tentokrát je pravděpodobnost,
že A se nerovná B, ta větší z obou,
ale to je dobře, protože v tomto případě Alice a Bob vyhrají, když
A a B nejsou stejné.
Takže opět vyhrají s
pravděpodobností přibližně 85 %.
Protože vyhrávají v každém
případě se stejnou pravděpodobností, která je dvě plus odmocnina ze dvou
vydělená čtyřmi neboli přibližně 85 %,
je to celková pravděpodobnost
jejich výhry.
To je lepší než jakákoli klasická strategie v této hře, a to je důvod, proč je to zajímavé.
Tato pravděpodobnost výhry je
optimální pro jakoukoli kvantovou strategii – lepší výsledek než tento nelze dosáhnout pomocí žádného provázaného stavu.
Tento fakt je znám jako Tsirelsonova nerovnost – pojmenována po Borisi Tsirelsonovi, který ji jako první dokázal, a podle mých znalostí byl
jedním z prvních lidí,
kdo popsal tento příklad jako hru. Pro případ, že analýza,
kterou jsme právě prošli, se zdá trochu záhadná,
je možné přemýšlet
o ní geometricky, což by mohlo pomoci
získat lepší pochopení volby úhlů.
Konkrétně, pokud použijeme
vzorec, který vidíš zde, který snadno odvodíme
z výrazů,
které jsme již nalezli pro
příslušné skalární součiny, pak můžeme alternativně
vyjádřit pravděpodobnosti různých možných
výsledků měření
WEBVTT
ve čtyřech případech takto: zaprvé, pokud se X, Y rovná nula, nula, toto jsou pravděpodobnosti
různých výsledků měření, přičemž se musíš buď vrátit nebo podívat zpět na analýzu,
kterou jsme právě prošli, abychom to odvodili pomocí našeho vzorce.
Zde vidíme různé
vektory stavů nakreslené jak dříve, přičemž barevné kódování je takové, že modrá odpovídá
výsledku nula a červená
odpovídá výsledku jedna.
Vidíš, že úhel
mezi modrými vektory a úhel mezi červenými
vektory je relativně malý –
v obou případech je to pí nad osm, takže cosinus je relativně velký, a to znamená, že pravděpodobnost, že oba výsledky
jsou stejné, je relativně velká.
V případě, že se X, Y rovná nula, jedna, je situace podobná – úhly mezi vektory se stejnou barvou jsou malé,
takže pravděpodobnost
stejných výsledků je opět relativně velká.
Třetí případ je podobný, a ve čtvrtém případě,
kdy se X, Y rovná jedna, jedna, se stane něco zajímavého – tentokrát jen tím způsobem,
jakým byly tyto vektory zvoleny, vidíme, že úhly mezi
vektory se stejnou barvou
jsou relativně velké, konkrétně úhly jsou tři krát
pí nad osm v obou případech.
To znamená, že pravděpodobnost
toho, že výsledky měření jsou stejné, je relativně malá, ale toto je jediný případ,
ve kterém Alice a Bob vyhrají,
když se jejich odpovědi liší,
takže to je to, co chceme.
Opět, zde jsou vektory: když se X, Y rovná nula, nula,
když se X, Y rovná nula, jedna,
když se X, Y rovná jedna, nula,
a když se X, Y rovná jedna, jedna.
A snad tato geometrická
představa pomáhá budovat intuici
pro to, jak tato strategie funguje
a proč byly různé úhly zvoleny tak, jak byly.
Na závěr lekce zmíním několik stručných
poznámek o CHSH game.
Zaprvé, jak jsem již zmínil, tento příklad není vždy
popisován jako hra.
Ve fyzikální komunitě je například běžnější,
že příklad je popisován jednoduše jako experiment, nikoli jako hra,
přičemž Alice a Bob jsou
chápáni jako detektory, nikoli hráči.
Základní myšlenka experimentu, jako je tento, kde provázanost vede
ke statistickým výsledkům, které jsou neslučitelné s
jakýmkoli klasickým popisem,
nebo obecněji s jakoukoli
teorií založenou na takzvaných lokálních skrytých proměnných,
pochází od Johna Bella – jmenovce Bellových stavů –
a proto se na takové
experimenty často odkazuje jako na Bellovy testy.
Někdy se také hovoří
o Bellově teorému, který lze formulovat různými způsoby, ale v podstatě říká, že kvantová mechanika
není slučitelná s takzvanými teoriemi lokálních skrytých proměnných.
CHSH game nebo nerovnost je v podstatě velmi pěkný a čistý
příklad Bellova testu,
přičemž tento příklad si
můžeš představit jako důkaz nebo demonstraci Bellova teorému.
Druhá poznámka: CHSH game nám nabízí jeden způsob, jak experimentálně testovat, zda teorie kvantových informací
je přesnou teorií. Skutečně lze sestavit experimenty, které implementují CHSH game,
včetně strategie
založené na provázanosti, kterou jsem právě popsal,
a podívat se, zda funguje – a funguje.
To nám poskytuje
vysoký stupeň jistoty, že provázanost je skutečná, a na rozdíl od možná
vágních nebo poetických způsobů,
jakými se snažíme vysvětlit provázanost, CHSH game nebo experiment
nám poskytuje konkrétní
a testovatelný způsob, jak provázanost pozorovat.
Pokud to zní důležitě,
je to proto, že to důležité je, přičemž Nobelova cena za fyziku z roku 2022
to přesně uznává.
Cena byla udělena
Alainu Aspectovi, Johnu Clauserovi – tomu C v CHSH – a Antonu Zeilingerovi
za experimenty s provázanými fotony, které prokázaly porušení
Bellových nerovností, jinými slovy ukázaly, že kvantové strategie
takového druhu, jaký jsem popsal, skutečně fungují a překonávají klasické strategie.
A pokud tě zajímá
dozvědět se více, doporučuji podívat se
na video o Bellově teorému od mé kolegyně Olivie Lanes,
přímo zde na YouTube kanálu Qiskit.
A nakonec, téma
nelokálních her obecně je skutečně fascinující a jde o aktivní oblast výzkumu,
která propojuje
fyziku, informatiku a čistou matematiku, přičemž stále existuje mnoho
zajímavých otázek
o nelokálních hrách,
které dodnes zůstávají nezodpovězeny.
A to je konec čtvrté lekce, jakož i konec
první části série o základech kvantových informací.
První lekce vysvětlila,
jak kvantové informace fungují pro jednotlivé systémy v izolaci, a druhá lekce vysvětlila, jak kvantové informace
fungují pro vícečetné systémy,
což poměrně přirozeně vyplývá z toho, jak fungují pro jednotlivé systémy.
WEBVTT
Třetí lekce představila
model quantum circuit výpočtu, a ve čtvrté lekci jsme se podívali na tři důležité příklady
ilustrující věci, které dokážeme
dělat s provázaností.
Cestou jsme viděli některé velmi důležité matematické pojmy,
včetně tenzorových součinů a skalárních součinů, a pozorovali jsme
některá zásadní omezení
kvantových informací.
Doufám, že se přidáš
k další části série, která bude o kvantových algoritmech, kde se zaměříme na otázku,
jaké výpočetní výhody
kvantové informace nabízejí.
Nashledanou.